[Music]
[Laughter]
this podcast is brought to you by cash
up with cash up investing you can buy
fractional shares of stock with as
little as one dollar if that sounds
daunting don't worry cash happy sharing
some big do's and don'ts of stock
trading to get you started
do assault your stocks they'll keep
longer don't take stop stock tips from
children they have less developed brains
than you and I and they don't know what
they're talking about do get coffee with
the company's mascot to see how you like
the vibe before investing
don't make your phone into a pie to
teach the stock market a lesson your
phone doesn't know how the stock market
behaves and it's not their fault
punishing it won't help do is set up a
folding chair on the floor of the New
York Stock Exchange with a big bucket of
popcorn and yell is better than
Hollywood don't set up your phone as a
bullseye and use a bow and arrow to make
trades there's an obscure law that
classifies this as insider trading and
you'll be arrested do yell Ben Bernanke
bless this mess every time you make a
trade and finally don't forget to use
promo code Congrats when you download
cash app from the App Store or Google
Play Store today
you'll receive $10 and cash out we'll
send $10 to the trevor project brokerage
services are provided by cash app
investing and subsidiary a sub
subsidiary of square and member s IPC
[Music]
hey it's it this is it congratulations
episode 150 we told you we might have a
special thing going on and we do a bit
it's me and my brother Matt Olien up a
bit or we even get going I got to plug
my New Year's Eve date in Chicago there
are still some tickets left celebrate
New Year's Eve with me and if you don't
and you live in Chicago and you don't
celebrate New Year's Eve with me then
you don't love me or you don't let my
brother in don't let my family so it's
all good but that's how it is if you
live in Chicago and you don't come you
don't let me know don't let my brother
that's on the episode right now so
Chicago New Year's Eve Chris D'Elia calm
for tickets live at grizzly grizzly but
we've got Matt D'Elia here for the 150th
episode of congratulations and and and
he's here so hello Matt hey you said it
was special when you were talking about
150 yeah and then you walked it back
because you said a bit afterwards right
it's a bit special it's a bit special a
bit special is is I think actually kind
of nicer than saying it's special
how about how you think about that how's
that because you know what dude it's
like it's it's a bit special like it's
not just the regular thing it's a bit
special right if I say it's special then
I sound like a [ __ ] cause it's just my
podcast mm you know I mean it would be
special I guess it would be reap like
really special would be like if you know
I had I don't know somebody who was back
from the dead so like [ __ ] Sinatra JFK
sure all of that didn't want me to do my
Sinatra thing but okay sure no Sinatra's
good yeah so anyway what you know it was
interesting though when we started the
podcast though immediately I told one
fire to not start right away and then he
immediately started right away right
which is again tonight so that's so that
sucks right yeah so you agree he's one
fire right I saw it happen in real time
in real time yeah and he he basically
proved why that's his name right yeah
okay so we got some things to talk about
and mostly we like to just come up and
[ __ ] though you know cuz we just
hang out in anyway and we like to do
that but I got a new tattoo so oh yeah
I'm a little cooler you want to talk
about that a little bit
I don't know what do you think about it
I like it I like it more than your first
one why slight this to your first one
yeah I just think it looks cooler hmm
I like that how it goes all the way
around like that yeah it doesn't look
cooler though it looks the same cool did
you know that I don't think I did know
that yeah I don't because I don't think
you have to think something it'll to
have that opinion right now it and I
don't think that it's a ten they're both
tens on the on the on the tattoo scale I
think the second one is a ten yeah the
first one is different than a ten hmm
you're saying like a 9 or an 8 just
different than a 10 so definitely I mean
stood deniro different ten times nine or
eight that's different that time you
know so anyway dude I don't know you
know you [ __ ] you've been into
tie-dyed lately a lot I'm weighing it
tighter yeah wait let me also say also
you washed your hair recently yeah yeah
yeah and you trimmed your beard yeah now
yeah you did yeah cuz it used to be
really really straggly on the neck here
okay well now your sirness
I'm not well I had an issue with no I
didn't have an issue with it was real
scraggly on your neck a little bit you
like you had a problem no it looks it
looks a lot better like this you look
really good
thanks you look more handsome so I'm a
10 now and it was before it was
something all different than attend a
different level pan so I got I got like
3 tied eye hoodies you gave me a tie-dye
hoodie yeah
I was hired a hoodie in the car just in
case I want to put it on yeah but I got
a tie-dyed t-shirt right now cool cool
cool that's too much too much tight it's
entirely too much tied I so but that's
very cool I really like Todd I remember
when I was in high school when I was in
high school I was thinking about how I
didn't want to do tie-dyed and I thought
I would never wear tie-dyed and then and
then I got older and and this past year
I was like I guess I gotta give up cuz
it looks really [ __ ] bitching and now
I saw the life reps hoodies and their
tie-dye
oh yeah that's what's up and that's that
the whole thing one time GJ Lee when I
was younger in high school digitally was
a guy in high school and he said you
become what you hate
he said that in high school yep and it's
so true dude and I wasn't son zu the
high school years yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yeah yeah yeah he said he said
you become with you hate night and I
never ever [ __ ] don't think about that
so that's cool that when I was in high
school a [ __ ] JJ Lee from high school
from from from aakhirah California said
tell me that
you become a hate and we were in locking
out it and I still [ __ ] believe that
sounds cool you know what that makes me
think of though which I hate mmm is how
kids will say [ __ ] like that just cuz
they heard in adults right I know he did
of course he did yeah yeah he didn't
even know what it meant
yeah he was right right oh he got lucky
right but he was just parroting like
some [ __ ] his dad or uncle or somebody
in a movie set I know I don't like that
no I don't like it either but it now its
effects if it affects my life and I
[ __ ] think Utley I guarantee that you
did more than anything to me when you
said JG Lee I just think of Jennifer
Jason Leigh he's that's why I mean oh
yeah I was Jennifer Jennifer Jason Leigh
when I was in high school said that
today no he was he was you know he was
cool he knew [ __ ] kung fu I think I
don't know who JJ Lee is I think you
might be making him up know I know
everybody there was a really handsome
guy dude remember when when we were
younger when you were in high school I
don't think I was even in high school
yet you would come into my room really
really really late and do impressions
yeah oh yeah dude one on your basketball
yeah and I played basketball when I was
in sophomore year it was yeah you played
left Ben I know that's such a stupid
[ __ ] dad job so yeah no I did I did
all of them and I did all of them very
very badly no they were good no they
weren't I mean she can I blow them up
like a nice sure yeah it was Robert see
strim Derek yi oh wow yeah turkey threw
him I throw up in my [ __ ] car once
and didn't give me a good enough a
couple of apology and I'm [ __ ] still
mad at him for it
that's movement to most McGillicuddy's
dude it was so [ __ ] annoying man we
were in Pasadena one of my best friends
Mike Stevens okay he was he was like we
were Derek got so [ __ ] he drank like
mind erasers or some [ __ ]
first of all don't have a drink called
mind eraser okay something yeah and
Derek Yi dude he was first of all Derek
he was so he was so loud
okay and he goes like this and he would
go like this Oh have you seen it like he
was like right now like this is probably
what he this is what he did all the time
he'd be like have you seen the irishman
and I'll be like no he said and then he
said oh you haven't seen it oh it makes
me so mad you don't answer the same
question twice yeah okay we're not
understand you asked me once I said no
and I didn't see it in the amount of
time the [ __ ] two seconds before you
just asked me right
so the
answer is now he will be like dude do
you did you see what happened yesterday
at lunch no oh you didn't and I go no so
that guy that guy [ __ ] that guy
that's that guy okay first of all really
tall Chinese kid super tall for some
reason I don't know how he got so tall
being a Chinese guy and he played
basketball he was like the center and
then he would also say John Kemp oh he
would always say Shawn Kemp is the most
entertaining player in the NBA
yeah and that pissed me off because I
believed it but when he said it I got
more mad that I felt the same way that
he did because he was the kind of guy
that's the same question twice now we a
year after high school went to Moose
McGillicuddy's or whatever the [ __ ] it
was it was a bar in Pasadena and well
there was her first mistake I know I
know I know I know I won with Mike
Stevens and Derrick got so [ __ ] drunk
that they had to be like yo man you have
to get out of the car okay there he is
Wow Wow he would be like you got to get
out of the car also he was like the kind
of guy I don't even know he had like
braces until he was like 35 I don't know
how it happened but he had it for like
20 years so Wow that's him yeah it's not
too big he wasn't [ __ ] tie-dye in
that pic it was he no but he would wear
so [ __ ] he would wear like a [ __ ]
shorts that were so big that were just
basically painted dressed like Kevin
Smith so so so he would say so he would
so he got so drunk they throw my look on
the bar and then we went back to my car
and I was like yo Mike he's gonna throw
up in the back of my car and Derrick's
like I'm not going to throw up in the
back of your car and I was like no
you're gonna throw up in the back of my
car and he was like I'm gonna be okay
and Mike was like dude it's gonna be
fine trust me I've been drunk a lot I
had never been drink yeah so I was like
it looks like he's gonna throw up in my
back of my car and he says he's not and
Derrick II literally puts his hands in
like he's crawling into the backseat of
my car and as he caught it was like he
went into my car to throw up
it was legitimately like he just went I
am NOT going to throw up John Kemp is
the most entertaining player in the NBA
and he goes tick tick tick with his
hands tick tick black and just throws up
so much and then I couldn't get in touch
with him the next day which [ __ ] made
me [ __ ] rip roarin mad dude because
obviously get in touch with me if you
throw up if you [ __ ] he'll act all
over the backseat of my [ __ ] on
boy get in touch with the next day dude
Derek yack dude he did oh did I throw up
in your car yeah I did but he didn't
apologize I didn't know it was I think
it was too embarrassed but was so
annoying he would tuck his shirts in no
matter what and I got so mad oh dude he
would wear oh my god I forgot about this
dude he would only wear [ __ ] t-shirts
with a pocket and the pocket would have
Bugs Bunny coming out of it with a
basketball Wow always or it would be
like somebody dunking a basketball in
was dude the guy loved that basketball
man it's so [ __ ] funny how many
Asians loved [ __ ] basketball in LA
cañada dude well there were just a lot
of Asians yeah but they loved the
basketball man it was insane
they loved it Wow John Kemp I remember
that from your impression yeah that's
right I would come he said John can be
the most entertaining player in the NBA
yeah you keep me up yep [ __ ] so late
and actually I would hey dude these are
the shirts he would wear they're there
they're always like funny little design
look that he would have had that that's
the derogate that had it wow that's so
bad these are the least fashionable
clothing of all time that's bad yeah
Wow anyway so um what what it was about
yeah Blaire Schober was another guy uh
yeah who's the strongest man alive he
was he literally always he's 510 who's
the strongest man 11 was unbelievable
but that was the kind of thing you would
do this a lot when we were kids you
would [ __ ] you would do something
that like before you would do it I would
dread it like I hated oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah while you were doing it yeah yeah
it was it was actually funny so I I
didn't want to like not laugh yeah like
it was like dreadful experience I was
like yeah I was laughing yeah it's like
how I watch documentaries you didn't I
don't want to watch it and then when you
turn it on I'm like oh [ __ ] that guy's
cancer and I'm all in yeah I don't like
to watch documentaries oh yeah you don't
likes documentary yeah it's weird being
a filmmaker to which you are you don't
like watching documentaries which is
crazy cuz filmmakers love documentary
the thing about documentaries is that I
already agree with you it it's so
dependent on the subject right that you
can get lucky make a shitty movie what
is
besides the subject this shitty movie
and it's a great documentary because
it's about a [ __ ] insane thing hmm
yeah right it's not even necessarily
good documentaries just a good subject
yeah yeah and so I specifically I think
because I'm I make movies and I think
about them that way I feel sort of I
don't know it's [ __ ] weird and the
other way around is true like you can
make the best documentary yeah but if
the [ __ ] person it's about or
something right it doesn't happen during
the making of it right right right
[ __ ] watch it right like if I made a
documentary about Derek II and it was
before he threw up in my car I will be
unlucky but if I got the moment he throw
up in my car and made it about how he
said he [ __ ] wouldn't throw up in my
car and then did throw up in my car
there'll be a great [ __ ] smash at
documentary I would watch like a
staircase version of that like an 8 hour
I would have to put it in parts like 7
at 7 episodes of like it you yeah just
like yeah I didn't I wasn't gonna throw
up in the car and I knew I wasn't gonna
throw up in this car and then the moment
changed once I got in his car so boring
and it's crazy because john kemp is
still down there tending player in the
NBA but we're not asking about that this
is not about basketball at all oh I know
I understand but and you can't wear that
shirt because of Licensing because it
has the Tasmanian Devil on the pocket I
mean how many do you have
he had all of them he any [ __ ]
character he had he definitely a
Tasmanian Devil one he had a [ __ ]
Daffy Duck and then he had a [ __ ] for
sure bugs but yeah like plenty of Bugs
Bunny ones it was so - like his mom that
got him for him yeah that was like oh
[ __ ] this is American you know
because she was not from America right
oh man was he trying to never [ __ ] is
that why he worked yeah no it you or no
that you were trying to do the
basketball 100% like a girl would come
over his house he'd be like you want to
go one-on-one she'd be like well I was
saying well then we can get a little bit
more in intimate and be like oh I could
just turn the lights out and we can play
what I want I bet no one no guy who's
ever worn is sure like that has ever had
sex like the day he wore it yeah you
know I mean like no one would have sex
with you if you're wearing that shirt as
the [ __ ] adult as a Bugs Bunny thing
like coming out of the thing yeah you're
sure yeah pocket maybe definitely only
well if you're a black I definitely you
have but not if you're a white guy no a
[ __ ] way yeah a black guys can wear
black guys can wear cartoon [ __ ] and
it's kind of dope
well what about what about
Asian guys like Derrick I don't know
what kind of you'd have to think about
Asian girls and be like oh but what are
they into they probably do like hard it
probably did right yes I may be but not
a white guy dude forget it if you're a
white guy and you were a Tasmanian Devil
coming out of the pocket and the [ __ ]
t-shirt there's no way you're getting
your dick wet yeah 0a0 money wait
there's no [ __ ] way dude if your name
is just like Tom or some [ __ ] and you're
like hey ladies how's it going and you
have [ __ ] legitimately Daffy Duck
going like this out of your [ __ ]
pocket get the [ __ ] out of here you
might as well literally have no dick or
elmer fudd dunking anyway dude so yes so
that's Derrick II and then there was
Blair Schober but you know the one time
do hood that you but then I came to see
you'd play baseball
oh yeah who was the guy that hit the
[ __ ] foul ball no that was Steven you
Steven you of course Derek II Steven you
okay cool anyway we [ __ ] there was I
was like the the older kid and I came to
see my brother play baseball and he hit
a ball Steven you hit a ball and it was
coming right at me because I was at the
foul line right like I was like off off
info territory out of my field yeah
that's it that's it okay so so he he hit
the ball and I was like oh [ __ ] and my
first thought was well [ __ ] I'm older
than everybody here I can get hit by a
base heartily because you know my
brother and his friends are gonna be
like oh is he [ __ ] Steven you hit
Chris D'Elia with the [ __ ] baseball
you're gonna die you're chunk now right
hey you're late you're less than but I
got to stay you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah I gotta stay [ __ ] being cool
so yeah I was like I was like oh [ __ ]
here it comes and I went I in my head
are murdered they can just pick away
come in don't [ __ ] hesitate and I did
I picked away but I picked the way that
the ball was a hundred percent curving
it was slicing it was absolutely slicing
it was like a golf ball I couldn't even
believe a baseball was slicing that much
and it it just nicked me and I moved I
had to end up diving out of the way but
also your back bent like yeah it was so
just stayed there yeah they wouldn't
even think that's a lot to you that's
why that was like the stupidest [ __ ]
most uncool [ __ ] and it was absolutely
essa [ __ ] because I [ __ ] had to bend
my body out of
the way yeah we it it was like Protoss a
[ __ ] it was pre before we were it was
it was it was I mean we were in high
school still you definitely were yeah
anyway yeah maybe before yeah yeah so
that's it I don't know but you know I so
Steven you and Derek II those guys
[ __ ] vomited in my car and hit me
with a baseball yeah it's a mocking at a
ship by the way are your house your
partner's going it's going good yeah
[ __ ] a lot of good guests it's weird
I love podcasts
yeah and I've listened to them for a
while but I never really knew how much
people want to listen to them yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy it's been the past three
years honestly when I first started
podcast like 25 year old girls didn't
even know the podcast was for real and
now they're like now they're like I
listened to your podcast I'm like oh you
know now that now not only do they know
what it is but they listen up [ __ ] a
bunch of podcast it's in C that's crazy
quickly they blew up and how much people
want enough to be listening to them I
know because people are [ __ ] bored of
[ __ ] and you're in your cubicle right
now listening high or you're driving in
the in the [ __ ] car hi Kevin Spacey
why do I know yeah you're driving in
your car
hi or you're in your cubicle hello
we said that last podcast right that we
always had a joke about how Kevin Spacey
walked in the room and says hi no matter
yeah I don't know I want to know oh
really thought you're the only without
me okay yeah so so here's the deal
though why do you ever do a podcast and
then you think why the [ __ ] this one
isn't that good um yes I have you have
okay yeah but they're all good and mine
that's what I feel every single time
well good that they're not good y'all
good I listened to your last podcast
yeah actually when I was coming up here
and I hated it you've lost your [ __ ]
mind
no that one was one of the best episodes
the beginning like the first ten minutes
you you just lost your yeah I can mind
it that's those are the best episodes
when I come in and I'm feeling good and
I know I feel like a tall drink of water
and [ __ ] like that and I'm gonna be like
oh I'm in a good I'm gonna get like
today I didn't get much [ __ ] sleep
this morning I think it much so [ __ ]
sleep so I feel like I'm not I'm a
little bit off
but it feels good because I'm talking
about Derek II and [ __ ] see that's the
other thing dude I don't give a [ __ ]
about I want it when I'm talkin I when I
listen to a podcast if I listen to a
podcast I listen to somebody talk I want
to know really I wanna you know okay
here's the bet here's what it is
for real okay if you're making a movie
and the movie is all explaining and [ __ ]
mmm I don't like it that's why John
Cassavetes is one of my favorite
directors okay exposition you don't want
that dude you don't know what the [ __ ]
anyone's saying yeah you don't know what
they mean you don't know what they're
referring to
yeah but it's their world and the
director captured it I agree
okay so in a podcast I'm talking about
Derek II I don't give a [ __ ] you never
met Derek you yeah okay this is what
this is my world I think it's funny that
he's got the [ __ ] Bugs Bunny [ __ ]
coming out of the pocket okay and I'm
gonna talk about it and if you don't
give a [ __ ] then tune out but here's the
other thing too when you're talking
about some [ __ ] that's very specific to
you and you [ __ ] are and it's all
your world and I don't necessarily know
about it that's the most interesting
[ __ ] to me yeah I agree I agree like the
end of Vanilla Sky oh my god okay when
the guys in the elevator and he's like
here's what happened on movie all right
yo [ __ ] yourself dude ya don't have that
scene yeah the whole movie was
rip-roaring awesome it was [ __ ] rip
roarin aw so my god
and then and then and then the elevator
he's like this is what happened I'm out
dude
yeah I'm out I don't want anything L me
what's going on do what you're doing and
I'll be that's like you got to treat me
like a [ __ ] hot chick man
treat me like a hot chick dude if you
want to have sex with a chick then you
just got to pretend like you don't give
a [ __ ] about her if you're like a ho ho
but sweetheart this is what I'm like
this is what I'm like sweetheart ahahaha
this is what I'm like right then the
girls like um check please
right and you're not even at a
restaurant my baby you know what's weird
I think that that is done because people
are constantly like are they gonna get
it are they gonna get yeah and it I feel
like everyone says like this is just
true I feel like people don't want the
explanation seen but it's done for
people who are expected to want the
explanation [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean I
don't even want to know what happened
like before the movie started bro
remember what I told you about JJ Lee
said that [ __ ]
becoming a hate and that's something
that I've resonated me originated with
me yes dude I was watching men in black
and another thing resin resonated with
me that Tommy Lee Jones said and I never
don't think about it
so wait hold on just before JJ Lee and
Tommy Lee Jones but Tom you have to have
Ali in your name okay but Tommy Lee
Jeung something that Tommy Lee Jones
says the Will Smith on a black man in
black stuck with you yes okay you're 12
well that was 12 I [ __ ] saw it oh I
thought you might you saw her recently
knowing it's stuck with you for this
many years 100% you got problems but
what is it this is what he said he said
will Will Smith is like I don't know man
people are smart and he said and Tommy
Lee Jones says no a person is smart
people are stupid and that's kind of
what it is and when that happened I
turned into the [ __ ] wee-bey mean I
went oh he's from the wire but that's
what I [ __ ] thought off yeah I mean
and I was like oh that's true and so
people don't a person doesn't want the
explanation but people want the
explanation but when I'm in a room with
people and we get the explanation I go
like this ah for [ __ ] sake but
everyone else is did we beam him oh he's
from the wire Wow
yeah right right right yeah I don't want
the explanation I don't want the
explanation at all but that is actually
pretty wise thing that Tommy Lee Jones
said in men in black I know it was
probably written but that would be crazy
if it was an ad it's not a documentary
if it was an ad lib and you ad libbed
people are tomorrow a person is smart
when people are stupid and then the
director was the wee baby who was that
oh we got to live it in did you see the
new men in black with [ __ ] the tube
people no I tell you what though I saw
the poster made me real mad Oh got it
well why I don't know well I don't know
dude
it just was like sometimes I'll see a
poster or see a trailer or hear about a
movie and it's just for some reason it's
like it's like the movie it feels like
the movie version of like a [ __ ]
Happy Meal like it's not a real movie oh
very interesting
it's not a real movie mmm it's just like
some [ __ ] put together for you to like
yes yeah yeah like here's the toy in it
- yeah exactly
not into it man Neal Brennan and I would
always text each other fake movies that
were coming out even though they were
real movies coming out like there's one
called like drunk parents with like Alec
Baldwin okay and it's just here let me
just drunk parents Alec
that's something yeah it's a real movie
dude we didn't yeah with some Hayek and
Alec Baldwin's sounds like the most
depressing movie let's watch his trailer
after we take a break we're gonna take a
break a little bit okay and then we'll
watch his trailer so we're taking a
break and we'll be right back me undies
by this time of year the planners and
virgos of the world have checked off
everything on their list while the rest
of us last-minute people are running
around like psychos trying to figure out
what to get everyone well don't fear
fellow last-minute gift errs me undies
has everyone on your list covered get it
double entendre covered
it's the one-stop shopping spot that
gets gifts that people will actually
love delivered straight to your door
free shipping no buts about it
get it actually all butts about it
because yeah you get it so I like them
because they're more comfortable than
any other underwear I've ever owned and
I'm 39 and I put on lots of underwears
on my life and they've got the patterns
I like they also got regular colors
which is the ones that I wear all the
time and this holiday season cozy up in
their new robes for men and women treat
your feet in their soft new slippers and
of course match the whole match the
whole fam with their cute new baby body
suit it's cold out it's dark out of like
4 p.m. and my undies wants you to know
that it's ok not to leave the house as
much as winter in sizes extra small to 4
XL me undies has a great offer for my
listeners for for any first-time
purchasers you get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because we have a 100% satisfaction
guaranteed to get your 15% off your
first first pair free shipping and a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
you go to me on DS comm / Congrats
that's Mandy's comm / Congrats quip the
holiday shopping season is here and this
year your gift can start next year's a
good habit with quip quip is something
that's sure to put a smile in everyone's
mouth because it's dental care they'll
actually want to use every day
to equip is the perfect thoughtful and
practical gift with an electric
toothbrush refillable floss and
toothpaste all intentionally designed to
make good habits simple look you can
give this gift this year and it's great
because it's cool but also it's good for
someone so if you know what to get them
you know you can have them practice good
habits join over 3 million happy
customers and check every one off your
gift list right now with quip it
delivers brush heads floss and
toothpaste refills every three months
just go to get quick calm / Congrats to
save on gift sets and to get your first
refill
free with a refill plan that's your
first refill free at get Q uip comm /
Congrats get quick calm / Congrats
hey guys we're back what's going on and
if you if you listen to the commercials
thanks so much man cuz you're helping me
[ __ ] back it up you know what I mean
no Dunst anyway no dance dude no [ __ ]
Dunst right insecure so this is a
[ __ ] trailer of a real movie called
drunk parents now I have not seen this
trailer I just know it's a movie
why because I travel on an airplane a
lot of the time and every now and then
you'll look at the [ __ ] [ __ ] when you
travel in an airplane and you see the
[ __ ] movies that are mm-hmm sometimes
you're like oh did they make these
movies sincerely just for American
Airlines right right that's what this
[ __ ] is like this movie is called drunk
parents it's with Alec Baldwin and some
Hayek
now what all I can say is of course it's
with them in it no I like Alec Bowman
I'm you know I want to say he's my buddy
but I've done his [ __ ] show a few
times you know I run into him he's a
good guy but this movie seems hilarious
I haven't looked at it yet I'm looking
it for the first time so I don't know if
we're gonna have [ __ ] you know we're
just a phone call away I love you guys
so much thank you for everything
can I help you I'm just doing my job I
just need a little more time why are you
finally put some neutral suit salesman
crap yeah that's what's-his-name ah this
is so boring so far I can't even believe
that this is something or sell something
what they've cut isn't it that's Kid
Cudi isn't it kid cootie hey cutie I
don't know that's my nickname why does
the sound sound so bad it's because it
was you know I mean if this play if this
was made anywhere but Vancouver I'll
[ __ ] straight a brick rip one of my
balls off oh wow I'll tell you why it
sounds so bad okay nobody gives a [ __ ]
oh yeah nobody that made that movie
gives a [ __ ] about anything sound guy
goes like this they go like this do we
get its anger goes like this yeah we got
it
let's go totally yeah oh yeah we got it
we about got it that's what he said
cause he's from Vancouver yeah break
does Alec Baldwin ever not wear that
coat in the in a movie by the way no
it's always a [ __ ] gray
double-breasted with [ __ ] gloves I
sort of got could be August in New
Orleans he's still wearing it what the
[ __ ] is this I don't know I don't know
what how is this a beginning of a
trailer okay okay okay so so far what
happened let's break down what happened
so of course sweeping shot sevinc over
okay yeah so she's going to college
they're together and they're leaving her
to college and he's wearing the coat
okay so work on every [ __ ] ring the
coat and she's always dressed for a
funeral for some reason okay so and the
college kid the interesting about the
college kid is she's 30 for it so that's
all good yeah so let's do this that was
by the way no humor or anything really
in that just just exposition in a
trailer which is crazy without that
terrible music you would actually have
no idea what's supposed to be a comedy
okay I'm just doing my job I just need a
little more time bar you find a way to
put some Newton lassoo sell some crap
finally a break okay so he's car gets
towed why I don't know he says I need a
little bit more time right we don't know
what that means for the car we don't
know what that means for the movie at
all yeah and you definitely don't know
what it means in relation to college or
a daughter leaving a hundred percent
okay so so okay so here we go okay now
he's talking on a phone let's just go
with an axe accountant
I was MasterCard yep he was talking in
and in the phone an act with an accent
yeah and his wife was watching him and
she's still dressed for a funeral and
how much did the dry the way he still
has the jacket how much did the director
beg him not to do the accent and he said
okay and then did it like that every
single time yeah yeah oh I won't do it
you want me to do it as a matter of fact
the director at the end he didn't
[ __ ] nine takes and directors like
yeah and he was like he was like did we
get it and then the director is like
sure because you know he's like okay
he's not gonna do it I told not to do
the accent and the eyeball says oh wait
well let's do one more because you said
you wanted one without the accent and
there was a yeah and they said in action
and he still did accent yeah okay so I
walked directly to his trailer yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so and then what does he
say here mr. Kerr that was mr. Kirk that
was my was master master card now that
was master this to Kirk okay Master Card
the lizard money okay going broke
they're going broke because it says a
going broke okay now Nigel is for sure
British come on you know he's going into
a wine cellar worth $800 who's supposed
to be looking after his property what's
next rented out this house rent out
Nigel's house that's the same again
that's Jim Gaffigan advance I think he
was sent from God as a new neighbor I'm
legally required to tell you that I am a
registered sex offender that's funny I
actually think that's funny I think
Africans funny very weird to go and
we're very weird to go in this trailer
absolutely we're absolutely weird the
most benign trailer so far and now all
of a sudden heat this guy's like I'm a
sex offender a new guy the only okay
okay so and I'm not
I love Gaffigan he's funny this is my
favorite part of the trailer hablo
sang-ok that i'm a registered sex
offender
come again Wow really pretty funny
actually okay as jokes go
he says come again that was funny funny
delivery alec baldwin yeah how they paul
was [ __ ] funny he's funny yeah okay
[Music]
we're going to jail we got to get out of
here just take what you need for the
next few weeks okay so I don't know I'm
lost
so he's the renting the house I don't
know there there are there anything the
house uh this Nigel's house yeah and
Nigel is away is getting pissed
cuz he's away and he heard the cops cops
called him because something happened is
yes and they're renting out Nigel's
house yes so far as has nothing to do
with drinking yes parenting drunk
parents no no or parenting yeah the kid
there was away at college still the
movie should be called Nigel's house yes
so yeah well actually I'm probably the
main problem I have with that is it
shouldn't be called drunk parents I
don't like titles like that okay like
it's just I mean you'd like bad weeks
[Applause]
you two are welcome to bunk in the twins
room Joe menja or whatever the [ __ ] the
hot guy the hackers in it
Hawkeye yeah the workout guy the human
the hottest guy what is up with this I
get mistaken for him all the time yeah
that's what D yeah what's the deal with
this movie I don't I mean I have was it
supposed it was definitely supposed to
come out in the theaters yeah Alec
Baldwin Salma Hayek showman man Giuliano
[ __ ] man Jena yellow I think [ __ ]
uh I mean Kid Cudi has a cameo I'm sure
he's the Cameo guy
and then the other guy Jim Gaffigan is
in it - yeah these are big be a gap it
doesn't look cheap either it doesn't not
you don't think so I mean it can't
really be that cheap but those people
ain't it for right true hilarious my
Frank and I can overcome anything as
long as we are those guys have booked
those guys right there
I'm telling you right now I don't know
this never seen him before I'm telling
you they've booked over 110 commercials
I mean look at those two guys those guys
have done so many commercials where they
go like this
yeah them yeah they make the face yeah
yeah yeah have you talked about the face
no you should talk about I will talk
about the face after this Alec Baldwin
this song
[Music]
[Laughter]
why how are you
I'm on the right side of the grassman
man what's the haps Wow what is it
called what they're not even drinking in
it
what's the haps that made me mad when he
said it I don't like that at all
ah you don't like that why not butters
isn't in so why don't you like that I
just not into like ending the trailer on
what ending it on that is bad yes not
good yeah yeah yeah they're not drinking
once in that - no not even a little bit
so that's the weird thing they might as
well call the [ __ ] Avatar 6 or some
[ __ ] it's not that either it would so
anyway the face yeah did you haven't no
I haven't actually it's uh every every
movie poster has this face on it every
comedy has his face on it yeah like this
right it's 99% of the time it's a guy
yeah it's also girls you know now it's
equal you know what I mean others 2019
girls now you making me some sexist
you're sexist and then it comes with the
face but every comedy if we look up
anyone look up any comedy poster look up
anyone with Tim Allen especially sitcoms
TV yeah that's the most most like look
at this situation I'm in right now how I
got myself into high jinks right right
catch you later they all doing it
they're all doing the words those guys
are doing that awkward moment
knocked up look at the knocked up one
that time he's tips stand up
scroll up there everyday that's the face
to a tee you almost got something on
just not right there yeah cause he
wasn't screwing up and I want him to
scroll up do it yeah yeah yeah that's
the most yeah yeah I don't know what it
is it's you know what it is because I
have done sitcoms and [ __ ] it's hard to
not do the face and if you do it once
they got that's the one they're gonna
use yeah I look it oh look it's you get
to go to bed go yeah go go go back to
the one you just said the Justin
Timberlake I'm getting pissed I'm gettin
pissed go back to Justin Timberlake one
you just had
and I'm pissed friends-with-benefits
dude [ __ ] Justin Timberlake right
yeah now the thing is just a duplicate
just making the face cuz he's a singer
and he's like oh this is the face of
actors do ya
what but that's the thing though people
uh people like when you're shooting the
[ __ ] for the stuff cuz they did it for
the sitcom and they were like hey you
know what's up what's up now how'd you
get yourself in this position like
they'll do that you'd be like I don't
know and I'm around and you're like I'll
[ __ ] then you're [ __ ] yeah so anyway
go see drunk parents all we have to do
is take a flight somewhere you can't ya
there's nowhere to see it yeah that
reminds me of that [ __ ] movie I did a
fake totally worse than death though
that's why I say he's in Vancouver oh
the other day wasn't Aaron in that yes
Aaron Paul was in it that's how we
became friends anyway that's what that's
what it is
so we take another break let's take
another break okay and then we'll be
right back
goat Yeezys Jordans off lights you're
going look if you're gonna buy sneakers
for a few hundred dollars how can you be
sure they're the real thing you want the
real thing trust me if you're walking
around with fake Easy's on and people
see it then it's very embarrassing okay
goat comm is the safest way to buy and
sell authentic sneakers online they're
the largest market place in the world
for authentic Yeezys Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listing listings they've
made the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy and they do this by only
accepting sellers with the best
reputation and by verifying all sneakers
to ensure their authenticity for buyers
every detail is inspected from the
stitching to the color to the size and
weight they certify every pair of
sneakers on their site matches exact
factory specifications I use it all the
time I've bought a bunch of stuff from
Goat it works it's awesome verified 100
cent at the time find the perfect 100%
authentic sneakers at koat.com /
Congrats that's goat comm / Congrats
plus you'll also be supporting our show
but you've got to go right now before
the sneakers you want or gone trust me
when you go to goat comm / Congrats that
spelled Geo 80 calm / congrats
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app the official app of the log
cabin what hi we're back
so yes so I don't know dude you know we
should watch that I never [ __ ]
watched on this podcast and I don't know
how I never [ __ ] watched in this
podcast is [ __ ] are these things and
I can't believe we I never [ __ ] watch
it and I thought it would be a good
thing to watch with you I can't believe
I never watched these but to catch a
predators oh my god these guys well the
way they try to lie is the best [ __ ] I
was watching one the pizza the guy had a
pizza
he brought a pizza oh this is the
goodness was this one dude he brought a
[ __ ] pizza first of all dude how many
syllables does the word it have it it's
it's Saturday like in the Connecticut
suburbs autumn is in the air in the way
and this guy graphics pizza to the door
is so far nothing this guy is bringing
pizza to the door letting it looks like
Robocop is looking at them look at this
oh wow thanks but I don't understand
that these guys text these things to who
they think is a 13 year old you know I
could be put in jail if the police found
out we were intimate sin criminal is
that is the worst thing to text some
yeah because that means that okay so you
know you know yeah you get what you're
doing is really bad yeah dude this guy
is si insecure when he gets caught dude
it's unbelievable so dude he [ __ ] is
there and she thinks she's 13 years old
she's laying it on thick yeah and she's
laying it on thick dude she's like
20-something you know and she's like my
good killing it doing acting in the
meantime if I was in this situation
which I never be I would never be in
this situation I would be like she's
laying it on too thick that's a girl
who's been to acting class she's 22 but
this guy is hoping so much that it's for
real okay like a perf breath
but somebody here is so nervous
there's no expectations well no oh look
at the way he said no but look what she
comes out look when he comes in yeah
hahaha like that like he's the dummy
yeah hanging out with
I tried to flip it on a flux right go
back the way he takes the water yeah
yeah yeah so [ __ ] nervous to grab
water you know the way he grabs the
water yeah cuz he has to do something
can I eat first and then he goes sure
he's so relaxed in convinced of his
innocence he eats a slice of pizza come
in who you are you know who he is
fumbling so hard with the pizza dude
it's so weird that this guy chose to eat
pizza in the sounds the weirdest
weirdest [ __ ] thing yeah also for any
of these [ __ ] to act like they
don't know who Chris Hansen is yeah I
don't know maybe this wasn't a while ago
I don't know I don't get it Boston man
drives two and a half hours to
Connecticut to bring pizza to a
thirteen-year-old girl that meets Chris
Hanson instead said basics - right - no
[ __ ] man what did you expect
didn't have any expectation no extra oh
well you [ __ ] definite expected to
eat some pizza I'll tell you that much
so you drove ours I like how we own
certain parts of it you know sure did
not a crime against driving two and a
half hours is there right through taking
the pizza the cheese is connected from
the end to the pizza can't get it off
and just relaxes into it and says who
are you
is the most ballin like I actually think
he could maybe get away with it with
that if he was just that I mean he just
like listen guy let's cut to the chase
who are you well he gets caught being a
pedophile I know well what else is he
gonna do at this point he's [ __ ] yeah
you have to just eat them at least enjoy
the pizza I guess last meal yeah your
dad look so cool probably should have
brought napkins a [ __ ] diamond dude
yeah eating pizza gets caught being a
pedophile and it's like just munching on
pizza like that yeah yeah being it like
a [ __ ] slob somebody after this Chan
did you bring some kind of a contract
into some sort of marriage pump he had a
marriage contract that he wanted her to
sign look at look at like a laughing at
him familiar while you enjoy your pizza
slammed him I should come Saturday well
since your mom isn't home it's the best
time to do it
yeah I would but only if you want me to
yeah I mean eating the pizza yes is
making me hungry I can't go to jail
right right right right that's not like
me right right is it difficuit that
can't go to jail life will be ruined
wow that was a good one could we liked
over 20 years
no shooing oh wow I can see why you know
a girl would like this guy this is
confidence you say do you trim your what
okay okay oh yeah uh okay sounds like me
- yeah okay okay you can bring that up
okay great you gonna bring that up you
know this girl's 13 right I'm sure she's
told oh wow
wasn't sure so he says wasn't sure how
old
Mazal just tell me because I can find
out like that
who are you can you tell me who you are
first I will tell you that in that
because you know now you're making me
nervous
and how oh yeah what you maybe want to
stop eating my pizza kind of losing my
appetite
honestly [ __ ] pizzas eating I was in
that pizza to now no Drive [ __ ]
housing that Pizza what I mean housing
yeah [ __ ] housing these [ __ ] it's
like oh no no no no no like a tree
trimmer or like a [ __ ] what they call
them tree booty call log [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah into 13 year old girls
like this you don't want to what am I
supposed to make it back
Azari I worked for meeting me know
potentially having sex oh okay so I mean
Stinnett you first of all why donors is
these guys when this guy shows up how do
you not believe Matt broke the set how
do you not leave immediately just leave
when that happens immediately right uh
yes I don't know dude I don't I don't
well he's he's so he is so [ __ ]
scared yeah well of course he is well
obviously but that's that explains every
weird [ __ ] up stupid thing he's doing
like his brain is just clearly not
working he knows it's Chris Hanson right
he knows how [ __ ] he is he knows he's
never gonna eat a pizza again in his
[ __ ] life all right
or that's all he's gonna be eating or
that's all he's going to be eating now I
can't stop the [ __ ] thinking about
how my [ __ ] voice is something like
that
or hats all he's going to be eating from
now on in [ __ ] jail
you know she's 13 don't you I have it
right here well you might as well tell
me who are you I will get to that I'll
let you know when
why won't Chris Hanson tell him who he
is because he that he knows once he
tells him that who he is and who he's
with that the guy's gonna leave and he
wants to get good television so it's
just entertainment value [ __ ] yes but
also
Chris Hanson didn't he have some [ __ ]
come out about him yeah you didn't know
about this did ya Chris Hanson uh what
would I call it
what would I in bounced a bunch of
checks really oh I thought you meant
like no no he did he had some like some
other stuff 26 no he [ __ ] it up and
they went free but also I thought he had
his own things where he was like trying
to [ __ ] run groom in or something not
now they're not young girls but I know
maybe I just made that up
my pride is made up I want to say that
no this
is a story and I will never ever watch
this YouTube video that begins like
that's never mind
hate when a video says it's a thing yes
not the singing dude or something yeah
[ __ ] just introducing it yep get you out
of there yeah get your view count up why
are you in the video of Chris Hanson
bounce it'll be like new Eminem song and
you be like collected be like what's up
you know how many have came out with a
new song and I'm like that's [ __ ] up
to do that but my buddy you know cuz
we're friends now right right right yeah
Eminem yeah yeah so anyway well okay
I'll that what is all what do you think
there's another thing I want to ask you
about okay since we've got you and such
a huge in the art world yeah what do you
think about the banana with the duct
tape there was a banana with the duct
tape that sole sold for what you do you
even know how much a hundred one hundred
and twenty thousand dollars and at Art
Basel right basil was he called I know I
know that okay and banette banana duct
tape to all sells for a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars my first
question because I actually don't know
the answer mmm-hmm it's not like mounted
you know what do you get what do you
take home the artist comes and puts it
on your wall and you exchange the banana
as as you feel needed like you should
replace the bunny you replace it and
when it when it gets brown you you can
replace it as much as you want I mean or
the artist comes along and replaces it
which either way is is it's either way
is stupid
okay huh why didn't that guy who wanted
it right just do it I can make my own
yes yeah because he's [ __ ] it because
he's a CUDA yeah that's the most CUDA
[ __ ] yeah so abhorrent artists on
Saturday afternoon eight I do you know
what happened to it by the way no I do
didn't read what hear about what
happened line got mad didn't call okay
so somebody bought it and then some
[ __ ] do you know about this you guys
came into the [ __ ] exhibit took it
off the wall ate it good well yeah that
guy's good but how funny is it that
he'll get arrested for that they can't
just use another [ __ ]
banana what's happening another banana
Wow
right it would have been brown by the
time I put up in the house it's better
somebody eats it it's called the
comedian which it shouldn't be it should
be called banana duct tape against wall
that's the worst part it's called the
comedian yeah
good to know
Wow the art which is what artists Eddie
you know the art was not compromised
anyway by the guy eating it well okay
well he was just getting so [ __ ]
nervous that he was gonna get 120 grand
right right right
oh oh you did it actually doesn't
compromise the art so you can still own
the art and I will get another banana
how's that and this is like a [ __ ]
Chris Farley movie doesn't that you'd be
like they wouldn't even make this movie
now this is unbelievable dude have you
seen will be the square
yeah but movie yeah about like art yes
the ridiculousness of the art yes I saw
some of it it this is like too
ridiculous right with that right I mean
I movies [ __ ] great you like that
movie yeah love yeah yeah yeah the
directors [ __ ] I saw a lot of it I
think maybe not all of it but I don't
know okay was it bad you know how I knew
way to go why do you do that because I
got how do you like a thing and y'all
finish it how's that work it's hard but
then I'll tell ya hey this hell but then
you wake up yes there's still more time
in your life and it's nishan but then
it's [ __ ] 10:00 a.m. the next day and
I got to get coffee dude you know how I
do it but you're answering the question
as if I'm asking you why you don't do it
immediately
right why don't you will eventually
finish the movie if you like I'll tell
you why the mood passes my babies now
the next question is why do you have the
taste in movies of a 12 year old no I
don't I watched the square you liked the
square you'd we watch each the square
and I told you why I fell asleep and
then the mood passed man what is that
it's my new thing that I'm doing
yeah well no but I felt it right now it
was cool I couldn't the angles bad so
wait if you could do it again I'll watch
it on that dude the mood passed my I'll
tell you what dude I saw last night
[ __ ] angel has fallen with [ __ ]
Morgan free reinjure ah Morgan
free remark and free free and Gerard but
but out of do throw a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Morgan free free and Gerard but but and
that [ __ ] movie it was not that good
to be our yeah I'll take but I swear to
god dude I would be in that movie in a
[ __ ] heartbeat do it yeah I would be
in that movie and a [ __ ] heartbeat
dude I do like to watch movies like I'll
be honest Morgan for III and Gerard but
but killed it dude and I call them that
because that's the mood of em oh wow yep
Gerard but but is so good at that really
is dude my he rips dude and he is just
like look you're gonna stay there no he
goes to Morgan free free he's like look
here's what you're gonna do you're gonna
follow me men will fall but you won't be
one of them and you're watching it in
your like Gerard but but dude that's
just the kind of move mood you're in my
baby Wow yeah you did do that so wait is
Morgan free free the president of
[ __ ] course how many times has Morgan
free free played the president so many
he was in deep in pain 9 times even in
movies were there is no president where
it's like about aliens he's like I'm the
president right I'm the president of you
aliens
Morgan free free has been the president
at least 7 times dude he was in deep
impact yep he was interesting how I'm
looking and then every time I moved my
head you move your head yeah the same
way I moved it yep blocking my view by
every single time just making me roll
man
yep look at this they ask what movie do
Morgan Freeman believe how many times
does Morgan Freeman play God who's put
the act present the most it's gotta be
him
no it's it's some old Sidney black mercy
Blackmer play it at six different films
from nineteen well that's [ __ ] weird
you know I know who Sidney Blackmore is
do you know who that is
no of course not cool and that's it
that's as far as we go with that but
yeah so anyway we watched that movie and
it was so [ __ ] uh you know it was so
that movie my [ __ ] is like it's so like
we're okay the fight away the first two
I thought were legitimately a [ __ ]
there were really cool action movies
this one will Olympus and lung
this one was okay I liked those movies
me too there yeah they're bad but I like
them why did you say they're bad one
time Bryant her slinger uh-huh he's a
director and he's a friend of ours and
he said that the one with Ben Affleck
and Morgan free--free been a foe and the
sum of all fears yes he said he said
that movies so good he was like that
movie so good he was like that there was
a montage in that movie that would that
rivals the one in The Godfather
that's what he said and my dad heard him
say that our dad well that's not good
and and he [ __ ] left so hard and he
got so mad at him and that's the end of
the story but um yeah that it was really
funny so uh and what was like what we're
talking about though oh yeah you why do
you think the bad well they're they're
not but they do it because you'd like to
if you like to watch something then I
think that that thing is good I don't
like the thing where people like it's a
guilty pleasure I know it's bad but I
write I don't do that I don't like that
either because if you like a thing then
you get just nothing guilty about it
yeah it's just good you just like it
yeah you like it and that's and if you
like stuff on the WB and if you like
that stuff that's just the kind of guy
you are you don't get to get you don't
get a skirt around not being that guy by
saying like it's a guilty pleasure
no just turns out Yeti it rad that's why
I don't write it right there it's like
it's like they're getting out of yeah
look I understand it's bad right but I
make an exception for this right no no
just like that you don't understand it
you don't understand it because Yeti it
yeah oh you're watching the arrow oh
well
are you watching all of the episodes oh
well do you enjoy it and is it a guilty
pleasure no turns out Yeti have you seen
the ads and robot have you have you seen
the ads and trailers for cats
oh yeah dude I spent 30 minutes talking
about this last time yeah yeah yeah we
all that never mind yeah but it's we
know what it is what I don't understand
is I don't understand people roasted
Sonic the Hedgehog when that [ __ ]
trailer came out I don't think it was
all that bad and they remade it and now
it looks better okay
why is not everybody
roasting the cats trailer they're not
doing that or not I haven't seen it not
like the sonic thing the sonic thing was
weird and it was very weird that they
recut it because of that
yeah was yet was yeah it was a lot of
men will fall but you won't I gotta be
in one of those movies I am actually in
one of those movies coming up so go [ __ ]
yourself oh yeah crazy right
yeah that's pretty crazy yep army of the
Dead on Netflix coming out so I mean son
secure the laughs it's not good I don't
know I'm also in you coming up so eat
that put that in your mic and polkas
okay Mike and poke ins yeah put in your
my compulsions um I keep [ __ ] getting
out of frame here but uh what we're
talking about yeah I don't know yeah
guilty pleasure [ __ ] yeah you ever seen
those things like like arrow or the
flash would never could never I like
you're 12 I watch I do I've seen one or
two episodes of them and well they're
not like the movies in the movie ones
are good I like I appreciate those like
what I like like [ __ ] Marvel [ __ ] and
DC some of the D shape see [ __ ] I do
oops yeah what you're making a mistake
by saying that mm okay well yeah you do
like that [ __ ] like well no that's this
is what I'm saying you like all [ __ ]
that 12 year olds like this is kind of
mood I'm in babies drunk but I'll tell
you what the one who I did see one
recently and I'm not gonna mention it
but it was in because I don't want to
[ __ ] because I do like those kinds of
movies but there was one movie that came
out and it was either a Marvel or DC
movie and it was a recent one and it
came out and I watch it on the plane and
I couldn't believe how much it was for
legitimately a seven year old I want to
know what it was but I'm not tell you I
thought a off-mike okay I don't even you
know I just know the superhero is about
I don't even remember the name it was
about you know the superhero but it
wasn't named after the super I don't
remember what the [ __ ] movie was
called it was called that superhero and
then whatever it is after that know how
they come up with the names afterward
cuz they have so many of them yeah they
need a colon and then a subtitle right
yeah there are so many of them it is
amazing how many of them are so much the
same there
but but all of those movies are all the
same like angel has fallen is like this
thing it's like I'm being set up and
it's like oh [ __ ] and they're like oh no
and they're like well I gotta get back
to my wife it's like all the same yeah
they are yeah you want to lose that
aren't the same or movies that [ __ ]
not everybody is gonna go see yeah for
some every now and then there's a movie
that [ __ ] breaks it like I don't know
his lady girl a [ __ ] movie or
something lady
what the [ __ ] was that it'll be called
lady lady world I didn't see it but
didn't [ __ ] Greta Vaughn girl would
do it or something
that's Lady Bird yeah that one's
probably like a 1 that's not like I mean
that's like a lot of it is okay well I
don't know it's just a different kind of
movie that it's a lot like better gone
girl would veteran and girl would what's
her name
Greta Gerwig ah okay I made her a little
bit more Dutch yeah or German you know
no I said it I don't know why it's on
there I never watched [ __ ] porn I
have a [ __ ] frequently visited on
pornhub and I don't [ __ ] watch it I
also have the Help Center on Twitter
I've [ __ ] never clicked on that he's
probably won't fire hacking into my [ __ ]
also ice watch porn yeah I don't though
dude I mean I do sometimes I definitely
do sometimes I'm not saying I don't
[ __ ] watch porn but like right one
time I was in [ __ ] Starbucks and I I
guess I was watching porn earlier and I
[ __ ] open up my laptop and it just
went oh yeah in the middle of star brush
star burst Starbucks that I I i had it i
was watching on my phone like earlier in
the day and i oh car getting your car or
of course the girl I didn't really know
of course dude it's just pop and I was
like I didn't know what was happening to
so not get that figured the [ __ ] out
outtie Mercedes BMW Range Rover all of
your [ __ ] Bluetooth man don't
hook it into the Safari [ __ ] adver by
the way no one would think I want to get
in even no matter what the [ __ ] I'm
listen to do even if it's not porn it's
[ __ ] embarrassing that shit's for me
you ever have somebody talk come up to
you on the street and be like hey I saw
your Instagram dude shut the [ __ ] right
up dude that's for online don't talk
about my [ __ ] online in [ __ ] real
life you want me to get in a car all of
a sudden I'm [ __ ]
and into my Kia even and we're going on
a date with a girl I [ __ ] you oh you
never met her but you're going on a date
you girl you never met and then [ __ ]
getting in there all of a sudden yeah
let's go I've got my Kia from from from
oh yeah whoops
I was watching red tube red tube you
know I was just gonna say that name it
something different but yes so that
that's that's it I don't know you know
haha 150 episode though man it you know
yeah so unsecure hahaha what else should
we talk about before we go do you have
anything you want to talk about I can't
believe I love this [ __ ] dude I'll
tell you what man everyone that listens
to thanks so much right yeah yeah so I'm
secure again everyone listens to mine no
- thanks so much for that - let me ask
you something for my mouth yeah what
happened did did you would he fall on
the calamari thing that woman a comment
singing I'm happy brought this up but
you agree with me I agree with you thank
you and that's the show about 85 to 90%
k oh there's a little bit that I agree
with him about okay and what do you
agree with him about well I just
my dad [ __ ] 82 Calamari's on one for
one fell off in the sauce and he [ __ ]
ate the a1 and dipped halfway in the
sauce and then he [ __ ] scooped out
the other one all the way in the sauce
and then ate the [ __ ] up the one and
he didn't care which one he liked better
absolutely asinine well you have a
problem with the fact that he even
grabbed two in the first place well you
can grab two as long as you know what
the [ __ ] kind of sauce are getting
involved with the two how could you know
because you control the dipping [ __ ]
capability the guy was really nearly
[ __ ] dangling off the thing like he
was spinning plates yeah and the way he
just goes about the second one I'm just
like god damn dude you're 72 it was
amazing how quickly that to be that into
something that everyone was talking
about yeah
kid and now you can't even tell you how
I know I talk about this too much but
that's the [ __ ] I cannot believe how
different I'm so much like dad but I'm
so much I would never do that dude and
those are the hard-hitting issues to be
honest you're not that much like talk
about the sum of all fears you're not
that much like him no no you would never
do the calamari thing no I don't mean
calamari but that's what I'm saying I
would never do that yeah yeah I would I
mean I honestly I wouldn't do that and
he made a grave mistake but I'm just not
as like hard on him about it because
what he says about you have to allow for
the fact that I like him like this
sometimes and I like him like that
sometimes you don't accept that no
that's fine dude
that's fine that really is fine but you
prefer it one way or another you can't
just say think about it
think about what you like that's all I
do all day long is think about things
and think about how I like it
and think about how I can [ __ ] think
about how it can how you can make that
happen to make it the thing you like
happen yeah but also like if it's funny
why is it funny and this is the rule
because this has to happen cuz if that
doesn't happen then this happens that's
always think about all day long mm-hm
and this guy is just [ __ ] willy-nilly
just learned willy-nilly just [ __ ]
letting Calamari's fall in the sauce I
mean it was did he let it though is the
thing
the easier way dude have it on the fork
fully dude it's like spirit fully he
didn't see only hanging on I was like
did you even know it was dangling
obvious I got it and I don't know Allah
are you [ __ ] insane dude that's that
doesn't help him at all yeah like how no
no if the [ __ ] thing is on it or not
that's it I don't we don't need to
[ __ ] do well on it but you know it's
just like you know I mean so quick so
yeah that's it
that's it we're over an hour now I guess
we don't need to talk about this anymore
or talk about anything but what have we
learn now I'm [ __ ] way cooler I got
the new tattoo you know we've learned
that Taita is the [ __ ] we learned that
was good
drunk right parents yep uh-huh somebody
watch that movie and what and and let me
know it shouldn't be called that and
then also we're done but I guess that's
it come to I'll do that I'll wrap this
[ __ ] up here but but come see me New
Year's Eve on on Chicago go get tickets
at Crystal combo you don't love me my
family right yeah we can grand that
download the cash out for free on the
App Store or Google Play market you
could text me at eight one eight two
three nine seventy eighty seven and OH
merch new merch where we stuck in that
life rip City I know everyone's [ __ ]
been wanting that so restocking that
pretty soon so beyond that pure Illinois
I'm gonna be there or really Ontario for
some reason I'll be an Irvine and
Pasadena in West Palm Beach Robinson
Ville Memphis made it oh no [ __ ]
Robinson Ville Rohnert Park California I
don't know we're on apart Oh Robinson
Ville Missouri no I think that's Memphis
Mississippi
I think that's Memphis Memphis is in the
state but it's in Memphis oh oh so what
would that be that Mississippi Robinson
real I'm going to Mississippi Missouri
but I do have a gig in Memphis that's
why I'm saying that
Robinson Ville Rob in Mississippi two
Mississippi
what the [ __ ] is that game Robinson
Ville Wow
when's my Memphis gig I do have a
Memphis casino coming up anyway also
listener confused which is Matt Delia's
podcast right area is confuse very good
Matt D'Elia is confused so sorry I mean
but I mean that brother and just typing
confused you'll get it and I've listened
to a bunch of the episodes they're
really very good he's much smarter than
me
and I don't know how you [ __ ] sit
there and interview people AB without
saying what the [ __ ] you're talking
about but you seem to be able to do it
it's got great guests on there and it's
really [ __ ] good so subscribe to that
as well and that's it I guess we're good
yous coming up on December
six thanks very much for listening and
we'll catch you later and remember
that's just the kind of mood I'm in my
babies thank you
[Music]